[Music]
hi my name is Dan
I'm here with hun young and sunny and
Saleem and we are from the Android
system UI and launcher teams
we always have some fun stuff and every
release we're going to talk about some
of it here some of his great stuff for
users some of it stuff you need to know
as developers either way we're really
proud of it these are the people that
built it I'm super proud to be up here
with them telling you about it so let's
we got a lot to talk about I want to
waste a lot of time on young why don't
you take it away tell us about new stuff
and icons okay thank you Dan hi
everybody my name is Han Yong Chun and
today I'm going to talk about new
changes that we introduced around
Launcher icons in a platform okay so
what is the problem that we're trying to
solve here one of the things that
developers like about Kyo Android icons
is that it's very flexible aside from
the constraints that play console impose
on you the 40 ACP size limit you can
choose whatever shape or size or padding
or shadow that you like of course
there's a material UI design guideline
around how you should do them but no not
all developers abide by them and so this
flex but and this flexibility is
actually a double-edged sword
because if you look at a lot of the OEM
launcher screens or whole screens what
you notice is that your icon doesn't
look the same as what you actually added
to your apk like this in this example of
Chrome and Play Store icon they shrink
it down and then they put it on a
background color that the OEM decided in
this example the same play console a
play Store icon is cut around the
corners and at least these icons of
preserve its original look sometimes
they will use icon packs which
completely changes how your brand
identity looks like and that's what
we're trying to solve in an adaptive
icon
so let's bring up the slides that you
may have seen Dan already presented
during what's new in Android oh so
there's a simple formula app developers
will provide foreground and background
layers one of these layers has to be
full bleed and opaque and the different
devices the OEM or the platform they
specify what kind of masks that will be
used on these icons and the user will
see if if the mask will circle then the
user will see circle shaped icons all
across the system UI surfaces and this
not only includes the launcher but all
but settings UI apps list app info page
and then also the reasons and overview
title bar and lastly the share sheet
dialog will also also use this launcher
icon so the shape will change throughout
these purposes if the mask was
roundedrect then the result will be
around direct icon so while we were
changing the Android the icon API we the
first thing that we also change is the
visible size of the icon previously it
used to be 48 DP but lately how there
are wider range of icon sizes that
different launchers third-party
launchers uses and some of them are 60
DP some of them are even 72 DP so we
decided that the visible size should be
72 DP but the foreground and background
layer that we actually want you to
operate to we want you to provide 108 DP
we want you to add 25% of the viewport
inset around four edges either using the
extension of your foreground layer or as
a transparency so that we can do delight
a delightful animation such as these
like the parallax and pulsing and
there's actually a lot more but
unfortunately on your todays developer
preview you will not see any of these
animations because we're still vetting
how to best place these but it will come
up in future releases
so let's talk about safe zone when
you're adding your main logo or the
badge of your icon in the foreground
layer you might be curious okay how do I
make sure that all of these show up on
every single platform and that's what
they've shown does for you if when om
defines their mask shape it cannot cut
into the safe zone and this is enforced
by the system by the API what this means
is that if you happen to have a badge on
the right bottom corner of this risky
zone that I labeled then what it will
mean is that if on if it's rendered on a
platform that is close to a rectangle
then it makes issues but if it's on a
device where in a circle mask shape it
will be clipped off or not shown at all
but I'm not saying that you should not
add badges just make sure that they're
inside the safe zone to be shown on
every platform okay so let's talk about
API the main class that we added to a
platform is adaptive icon drawable class
it supports two elements background and
foreground and one attribute drawable
where you can specify either the asset
or the or another basically you can
specify either a drawable or a color and
weirdest class fits in the drawable
family tree it's parents probably could
be the layer drawable and it's half
sibling will be the ripple drawable and
after you define this XML file you don't
actually specify this in Android
manifest file and the old Android icon
attribute is doing effect as a matter of
fact you do not remove the legacy icon
because in previous platforms p4o they
will not it will not know how to handle
or inflate adaptive icons so you still
have to keep this adaptive icon but
as of all what you do is you create a
same name XML file as the legacy PNG
asset and then add it into mid map any
dpi and whatever foreground and
background layer is neat like this I see
foreground Jake PNG you would add it to
the density specific map directory and
at compile time apt you will scan your
min map any dpi directory and if it's
these adaptive icon it will move to v26
particular directory so that only
platform 26 and above will inflate it
and use it one thing to note is that
some of you good to like Android citizen
may already know about this round icon
attribute that we added in NMR one if
you do you if you haven't read a few
Android developers that did use it then
we recommend that you create the same
name XML file as the legacy as the
ordinal adaptive icon file but the
contents can be the same now regarding
why we decided to not deprecated this
and why you have to override this I am
NOT going to go into detail but I
strongly argue to read them on our
website now some of you sitting in the
audience may think 108 DP that is really
huge and maybe to make the matter worse
your apk size is very close to hitting
that play console Mac size limit in
which case what you can do is in oh we
added a fraction type with the inside
Robo support fraction type and if you
remember the inset that I asked you to
add was 18 DP if you divide that by 108
that is 16% so if you specify 16% as
your insect you can then use your legacy
appoint the inside draw both main
content to be the legacy icon then there
will be no apk increase apk size
increase and you
you will be able to upgrade to adaptive
icons for free and as of Android n the
vector drawables became so much more
expressive that almost every element in
SVG file can now be supported in vector
drawables so if you actually use vector
drawables as either your foreground and
background element then your apk size
will actually decrease
and now I'm going to do a demo of how
the icon Wizards now support creating
adaptive icon wizard if you right-click
your resource directory and then choose
new image assets then you'll get this
page and here you can configure your
foreground you can select different
asset type as image I'm going to choose
image here and then what you're seeing
on the right side is this is a preview
of what your icon will look like on four
different platforms with different masks
and what you're adding into your apk is
actually presented here in full bleed
layers now you can toggle the show safe
zone to see if your foreground element
is fully within the safe zone and so
that you can ask you resize you make
sure that everything is the photograph
and in background layer I'm going to
change the color to something hopefully
hip not so hip okay whatever
and then that's what we're going to use
and the last type is actually very
important because as I mentioned earlier
if you just add adaptive icons your app
will not have any icons in previous
platforms so you can use this third tab
to generate the legacy icon the legacy
round icon for circle shaped mask shape
devices and then this you can also even
generate the 512 by 512 image that you
upload to your play console here and
then click Next and then this is the
same directory structure that I showed
you earlier on you say finish and then
since um before all devices become
available you can test this on the
emulator
and now I'm installing the app and as
you can see this is the icon that I just
created and this emulator has circle as
the mask
and oh okay oh and so what I'm showing
you right now is this is an option that
you can see on the main launcher of your
emulator it lets you first this is the
water should have been the main map
shape on this device a circle but just
for the developer purpose you can change
the icon shape so that you can check
what it will look like on other devices
and let's pick something fun like peer
drop and so now you have teardrop-shaped
icon without having to make any changes
that's all everything to adaptive icons
on that note I'll pass it off to Sonny
who will tell you more about shortcuts
I'm with it
thank you sir hello everyone
just now some song song talk about how
to make your app icons look even better
this helps a lot in improving your apps
experience another way to improve your
experience is by adding shortcuts
shortcuts allow us to expose deep links
directly on the user's home screen for
example a messenger app can expose
shortcuts for frequently use contacts
allowing the user to get to those
contacts quickly and at 10 define a
short codes using API define last year
in animal 1 we will create a shortcut
info object and pass in all the related
information like label icon and intent
then using the shortcut manager class it
can add update or delete this shorter
the system will manage the shortcut for
the app and even back double on the
clouds if needed this dynamically added
shortcuts are shown as additional
options for the app for example when you
long click the app icon but the launcher
can also allow the user to pin the
shortcuts on the home screen where they
exist as independent icons previously to
create this pin shortcuts an apple send
an installed shortcut broadcast and hope
that the launcher gets the broadcast and
does the right thing there are many
downsides to this flow for example the
app loses control and this movie for
that the mode that the shortcut was
added also since the user is not
involved in this flow there is a
potential for spam if starting with and
although this API will no longer work
instead the applicator shortcutting for
object as its main umbria slides and
call the request will shortcut API this
will make the launcher show fan
summation problem allowing the user to
pin the shortcut place the shortcut on
the home screen once the shortcut is
added it behaves like any other
shortcuts
can be updated using the existing API
another way to create shortcut is from
the widget raid an app can define a
custom short curve which shows that
consideration activity when the user
size to ask them on the home screen we
define a custom shortcut the app would
declare the configuration activity in
the manifest with the create shortcut
intent filter this is the activity which
is started before that before the user
as the shortcut on the home screen which
allows the user to configure the
shortcut from this activity the app
would return the shortcut as intent
extras directly to the launcher this has
similar downsides as the excel shortcut
flow that the app loses control and it
does not work cross profile in oh now
app can be isolated on a shortcut info
object and thus retain control over the
shortcut from the widget a user can also
add widget now this is the only way for
a user to add widget if an app wants to
add a widget it will have to explain to
the user how to go to the widget tray
which may vary from device to device now
in OH an app can simply call the request
pin up with Jade API this will show
confirmation from similar to that of a
shortcut and allow user to place the
widget on the home screen once the
widget has been added the app would get
the widget ID as part of the callback
and can be used to update the widget the
summarize the changes in salt shortcut
broadcast will no longer work on or
doesn't matter if the app is targeting
or not and absolute instead use the new
API is to add shortcuts and widget make
sure to check out the documentation for
more information on this API
[Applause]
I'll and already fighting for motivation
Thank You Sonny hello ever'one I'm
Celine and I'm here today to talk about
notifications notifications have been
one of the key components of Android for
many years and in each of our previous
releases we have continuously improved
on them in an or though we are further
improving our system in many different
areas let me first talk about the visual
changes we are doing the first key area
of improvements that we are doing is the
channel of visual notification hierarchy
per user not all notifications are
created alike so for example user cares
way more about the messaging
notification compared to a lower party
whether in education but in today's
world all notifications look very
similar and the user has really hard
time parsing its notifications so
starting Android oh where we're going to
be more opinionated about the order of
navigation in order to do this we're
dividing the section up in four
different areas on the very top we have
a new section called major ongoing below
these we have people to people
notifications followed tightly by
general channel notifications that
behave just the way they do today on the
very bottom we also have a new section
called by the way notifications let me
go into detail of into detail for all of
these sections so the very first section
that appears on the very top is called
major ongoing and it is reserved for
high-priority ongoing tasks good
examples here are music notifications
like an ongoing navigation notification
or basically only something that is
really important to the user and the
user must know that it exists there are
basically two ways how how a
notification can end up in this area the
first one doesn't require any developer
interaction at all and this reserved for
media notifications inserting in Android
oh we are going to colorize the
backgrounds of notifications based on
the media artwork
an example you can see on the slide as
you can see we are extracting the
background and the foreground color
directly from the album r4 and it will
create like a really nice structured
image the second way how a notification
can be colorized is by opting in by the
developer so a developer actually has to
do something if you want to get there
and the way to do is is it's reserved
for foreground service notifications and
they can use a new method called set
colorized on the Builder the the
background color will then be colorized
by the app provided notification color I
want to really stress here that please
please please don't abuse these styles
we're putting a lot of a lot of lot of
trust into the developer action system
and who see this if you see this being
abused too much we will have to change
it in the future another thing I really
want to stress that colorized isn't the
new white that by default a notification
shouldn't be colorized we don't want to
create a shade of rainbow colors we want
to achieve the opposite we want to put
focus under one and the one notification
that matters all right so below these
ongoing notifications we have
people-to-people notifications and the
research has shown that users usually
care about people notification than most
and if you're interested about that you
should definitely go to this talk
tomorrow it's happening at 12:30 and
it's the design talk and testing channel
if you're interested about how to post
notifications and how developers today
abused our notifications you should
really go there so in Android oh we're
transforming people to people
notifications by first of all ranking
them higher up such as the user sees
them more quickly and second of all
we're also expanding their size so even
in the collapse form the the user can
see up to three lines of text which
obviously makes it way easier to parse a
notification and this also happens
happens on a lock screen so if you have
been away from your phone and come back
you can immediately see like what is
relevant and get back to it
all right so below these people at the
people education as I said are the
channel notifications just the behave
just like they did before and so I won't
go into detail to that section so the
last section in the notification shade
is called by the way notifications and
this is completely new and as you can
see in Android oh we are transforming
these min party notifications to show
only a single line of text a user if
he's interested in it you can still make
that visible by clicking in either good
examples of notifications that should
appear there are like an ongoing traffic
notification the weather basically
anything that is important and cuts
actually relevant but not doesn't
require immediate attention all right so
this completes the visual notification
hierarchy and let's get to the next
feature we are working on so the other
feature we're working on is called
visual stability and let's consider a
situation you may be encounter every day
you're carefully crafting in you reply
to maybe your friend Salim and just
about when you were to hit Send then
obviously the whole notification just
gonna reorder and it sucks and probably
you hit the wrong notification and magic
stuff happens and you don't know what
happened and of course this is a really
bad experience and we want to prove on
it and so the goal sans relativism poll
don't reorder notifications while you're
looking at them and reality
unfortunately be slightly harder than it
sounds because if you get a new message
for example you still want to know about
that right and yeah we actually like
this feature so much that it's even
available in NMR to new backported it
there so if you have a phone already in
MO or two that's already there alright
so if you know me and you know me
personally I'm all about notifications
and I'm all about animations with
notifications I care about every little
detail and even like the slightest
little thing should be pixel perfect and
animated and in Android oh my designers
and my co-workers let me off my leash a
little bit and I was allowed to go wild
so I created this animation between an
expand and basically where we expand the
notification shade I think this slide
explains it way better than I ever could
but the key goal essentially is to
create a sense of object permanence a
user should always know where these
notifications are no matter redditor
collapse in an icon form in the in the
status bar or when they're expanded in
the tool notification shade and
obviously that needs to be a really nice
transition between those as you can see
by the way notifications appear on the
very bottom and they appear like as
overflow dots to indicate an overflow
and they go away when you close the
shade all right let me hand it over to
Dan to talk about channels and other
nice features thanks Lee oh hi it's me
again
notification channels is probably the
biggest piece of new API surface in the
notification system so and there's a lot
of interesting design decisions there
let's talk about it okay so let's just
start with like the base assumption that
apps post a lot of notifications like
like kind of a lot but okay because
users like notifications also kind of a
lot so there's actually a good state of
affairs and to tell you the full story
of channels I need to sort of stop for a
second and talk about my friend here it
might be your friend isn't my friend
this is the neurotransmitter dopamine
it's actually cartoon of the
neurotransmitter dopamine which is fine
because I'm not a neuroscientist so you
shouldn't really trust anything I say
about brain chemistry anyway but let's
just say that this is dopamine it's
really really complicated how it works
in the brain and the body it's involved
in all kinds of stuff but what we're
gonna talk about today is the things
that is associated with that I show here
so things like anticipation of reward
motivation seeking rewards your
attention salience your sort of you're
in the moment and looking for something
including the
right word for that slide it's basically
the user engagement chemical in your
brain and so bringing this back bring
this back to what we're talking about
here dopamine on its own doesn't make
you happy right there are lots of other
great neurotransmitters and chemicals
that make you feel happy and satisfied
that's not its purpose dopamine is to
get you there
okay and notifications work exactly the
same way they get your attention
you become you become attune to them you
anticipate a reward so you tap on it
maybe what's behind it is useful maybe
what's behind it is deeply satisfying
you hope it is maybe it's not so with
every app fighting for the users limited
attention span limited supply of
dopamine limited ability to care about
distractions and stuff that the device
wants to tell you suddenly you're not
nearly as excited about those
notifications at all and everybody loses
the user loses every app loses it's a
tragedy of the Commons in a classic
sense but I know that's actually not a
problem for anybody in here all of you I
can tell just by looking at you you've
all got good notifications like your
notifications are the ones that the user
really wants to see I know that I
understand we get ourselves but there
are other notifications out there that
are not doing so well
right so maybe met you messed up one
time and you made a notification that
had a really loud beeping tone and so
the user banned your app forever or like
me you had a new recommendation engine
and your machine learning like was kind
of in machine preschool and it didn't
recommend the right thing so the user
blocked your app or uninstalled it or
you're trying to try out some new kind
of notification that you know that some
of your users are going to love and
others are going to like yeah I could
take it or leave it and you're running
the risk of making them unhappy so the
Android way is to give users control
okay and Android already lets you have a
little bit of control over apps they're
maybe not quite matched to what you
expect other notifications you can
uninstall them in jellybean we added the
ability for you to block notifications
but leave the rest of the app working
just as it did and nougat we made that a
little more refined give you some more
options but in Android Oh we're
introducing notification channels so
channel is data structures that you
create and handle the notification
managers that
describes a category of notifications
from your app specific the channel is
specific to your app they don't match
any other apps channels everything on
the channel shares the same behavior and
you can see some icons representing the
behavior their behaviors like sound
vibration whether they pop up on the
screen whether they like the LED and so
forth then this category is arranged so
that the user can understand these
notifications and can control them
category of notifications from an app
with the same behavior so the user can
understand and control them alright I've
got an example here from a fictitious
airline crane air usually they post
notifications like your flight is
delayed which are really important or
here's your boarding pass also extremely
useful and then one day they post you
something that says you earn 25 60
points today you're only 500 points away
from being able to sit in a humane seats
so many users might really love this oh
my gosh that's fantastic I'll take that
last trip I'll get to that status level
others users might find ok wow I'm just
going to uninstall this app I don't need
that kind of garbage in my life in a
channels world in Android oh you can
long press this notification or use our
new short swipe gesture to get to the
inside of this notification the
inspector where you can see the app that
posted it of course we want that
accountability we introduced that in
nougat you also see the name of the
channel in this case the channel is the
executive program you see that there are
other channels available to sort of give
you context and of course you see here
it's called categories our user facing
name for this feature is categories but
of course you and I know that we already
had something inside the notification
API called categories so internally it's
called channels but we call it
categories in the in the UI string so if
you really you've got this notification
you long press you see this screen what
do you do you touch that switch on the
right-hand side and they're gone the
executive program notifications only are
gone every other notification from them
app works as it did before okay alright
so maybe maybe you didn't want to block
them like that's useful information but
if you know it beeped it made the phone
do something that you didn't like so
okay maybe this is the kind of
notification that you would prefer to be
more of the by the way sort that Salim
described so instead of hitting the
switch you touch all categories
all categories takes you into the
Android settings app this is not setting
surface that you create in your app this
is actually in settings that apk on the
ROM it shows you the app name it gives
you a big master switch that you can
block notifications as you always have
been able to do it's got a switch that
I'll tell you about at the end of the
talk and then it lists all the
categories and each of these corresponds
to one of the notification channel
objects you created and handed off to
the notification manager to partition
your space of notifications from this
space the user can quickly block or
unblock that Channel and even dig in
deeper to control the very specific
details of that behavior if you really
want to because again the point here is
that we're giving the user control over
everything the app can do before I move
on I want to point out that there's a
link at the bottom there that goes
straight to your apps own notification
settings we'll talk a little bit about
what goes here and what goes there but
just to show you an example if you touch
one of those channels you'll see a
screen a little bit like this where you
can again a block just that channel that
switch is the same as the one you saw in
the previous slide on the row item you
can touch change the importance which is
our new system that sort of replaces the
old priority API is if you're familiar
with those in this case importance is
what determines whether or not vacation
pops up make sound is unable to make
sound ends up in bTW and so forth you
can actually change the sound here you
can change the vibration and a whole
bunch of other stuff if you really like
a super fan of notifications but if
you're not you may never get this far
down into this screen and again we've
got another link to your apps settings
here and we'll put extra stuff in the
intent so you know exactly which channel
the user was trying to configure at that
time and it is actually also a little
description at the bottom you can set a
description to explain what the channel
is for I have a little bit of code here
just a little bit there's much more
extensive code samples obviously on D on
Android comm but this is effectively how
this is going to work to set up your
notification channels you create one the
most important thing is the channel ID
which is the first parameter to the
constructor there that's just a string
and it's totally whatever you want it to
be it becomes the unique identifier for
that channel when you post a
notification later everything else about
the channel you set up it's pretty
straightforward you give it a localized
string that the user can understand is
the title you give it the importance
that you would like for it to have you
give it the sound that you would like
for it to have you
the vibration that you would like for a
SAP and so on you set up all the initial
parameters all the behaviors of this
channel and then you tell the
notification manager please create this
now if you don't want to like track oh
did I ever did I ever done this on this
device before because the notification
manager of course persists all this
information between reboots you can do
this anytime your app or service starts
up and it's very cheap if the
notification manager sees that you
already made this channel you can
skipper it skips right over it so you
can do this
in any of your setup code and then we go
to post a notification you just throw it
into the Builder constructor and that's
it not that's it for the talk we've got
more things to talk about remember I
said that there was some question about
like what settings go where so there's
app settings the settings inside your
app and the settings that I've now shown
you are inside Android well truth be
told there were always two places for
notification settings there's always
been a thing that you can go to in
settings to control weather vibration
works how loud things are and so forth
but we've actually made a much clearer
distinction in about what the long as
we're in the app we're now letting you
we're saying focus on the business rules
so what when why of what kind of
notifications exists in your world when
they get posted what they mean like the
system doesn't want to know that you
have a geofencing feature or what your
social graph is that Android doesn't
care about all that you define all of
those rules the only thing that we're
moving over to Android settings is how
it behaves once it gets on screen or on
vibrator or on speakers and that's the
thing that then the user can make
editorial control of later okay there
are some questions when we describe this
about okay well I don't know how to
organize my channel so I have one per I
don't know like just one do I have okay
so here's a recommendation pick
something that makes sense pick
something that is going to make sense to
your users such that if the user says oh
I kind of want this set of things that
behave differently that defines your
channel so let's say that it's a you're
in some kind of you know business chat
app like maybe every room is its own
channel your app might even call them
channels already or perhaps a different
topic
a news app or a different sender a
different like you know chat grouped in
a messaging app anything that you want
the user to tweak in isolation or
anything that you need to behave
differently from your other
notifications put it in its own channel
because remember everything in a channel
behaves exactly the same way they all
have the same behavior so the user can
understand it control it we give you one
additional level of hierarchy just for
presentation just to make it a little
easier to organize in the Settings app
they're called notification groups I
didn't show you the code for that it's
really easy just give it a title and
assign us each Channel as you create it
this allows you to sort of segment
channels as we've done here it's really
useful for for example multiple accounts
so again this is the Settings app inside
Android you can see I've got one account
channel channel channel another account
channel channel channel so you can
control all of that independently and
again the user may never ever see this
screen they may just see notifications
doing exactly what they want but if you
long press it you say oh this is calls
you go in here oh it's called
specifically from my personal account
now I can make changes to that many of
you are already sitting there thinking
well okay I think I see some ways around
this we've been thinking about this for
a little while let's let's walk through
it first thing is the apps have a
million ways to be cruel to the user
stopping them is impossible what we want
to do is deal with obvious things right
because at an obvious abusive app like
results and uninstalls results in bad
rating is bad reviews you don't want
that okay so now we have to worry about
the sneaky things and for sneaky things
again we want to either prevent them if
we can or move them into the obvious
category which we know how to deal with
so here's an example of something that
an app could do oh well if the user
changes the channel setting is like oh I
want to block that channel or I want to
put it in bTW well what if I just change
it back and our mitigation for that is
the API doesn't let you once the user
has voted the channel is locked you
can't make changes to it after you
created it the user has the final set in
what that channel does period okay all
right so okay if I can't change the
channel settings of what I'm just going
to delete that channel that has
properties I don't like and it create a
new one okay fine thanks for gaslighting
the user so what we do in the Settings
app is
actually show you how many channels the
app has deleted we don't show you
exactly what they are for privacy
reasons so that an app can actually like
clear at the state and not leak
information about you but you can go
into settings and see yeah I feel like I
blocked that like five times before oh
yeah sure of five deleted channels
mm-hmm okay now the app's malfeasance is
obvious okay well alright I feel like I
just want to opt out of all of this can
I please just like make one channel for
everything you can do that and if your
app only has one thing that it does like
it just chimes on the hour that probably
makes sense but if what you're doing is
saying I want my critical notifications
to be tied in fate to my recommendations
or my speculative notifications then the
user is going to have a bad time and
you're going to have a bad time because
all those notifications will behave the
same way and they'll get blocked
together okay
wrapping up on channels you set up your
categories after that the users in
control of how they behave the user
happiness should be your goal you work
to make the user happy the user will get
the notifications that they want that
you want them to see everybody gets
their dopamine and serotonin and
norepinephrine and what I again I don't
I think that's no anyway one more thing
that I want to mention before we go we
only have another minute left channels
are mandatory once you target Oh
specifically once you target API 26
before API 26 you can start using these
API so I'm start moving your
notifications over two channels
piecemeal once you start targeting Oh
any notification you post that doesn't
have a channel gets dropped on the floor
I should have done that with a clicker a
notification gets dropped just it never
shows up to the user so this is
definitely something that you have a
limited amount of time to move
everything over we sort of take a look
at your notifications organize them into
channels you'll be amazed at how many
teams are like I you know I didn't even
really realize how many notifications we
post what a great time to take stock and
clean house and get things organized so
that you can go from this situation
where all the notifications are
competing for your attention and
draining your will to live and go to
this situation where there's nothing on
this slide go to this situation where
the user sees the ones that they want to
see in the order they want to see them
and is very happy and blinky and so
for it oh one last thing and we've got
almost no time we did introduce badges
on app icons that sort of slipped out in
the keynote a kind of a late-breaking
thing but we wanted to do the Android
thing and make them low anxiety give the
user control over them make them look
nice and fundamentally make them
oriented around our notification system
so what you'll see in the beta is we
call notification dots the dot just
means there are notifications for this
app you get to choose as an app which of
your channels get dots so for example a
music player wouldn't have a dot for its
playback controls but it would have a
dot for its recommendations and users
can turn those on and off per channel or
globally across the system as they will
if you dismiss a notification the dot
disappears to the users in total control
[Music]